is coronavirus a pandemic or a dem panic
should we lather ourselves and hand
sanitizer to keep come flu away or is
the left-wing media blowing the Wuhan
virus out of proportion we will examine
the facts as well as many other funny
names for the public health crisis then
Kamala Harris endorses a man she
considers a vile racist Hillary Clinton
refuses to endorse anybody and MSNBC's
Brian Williams teams up with New York
Times editorial board member Mara gay to
fail at basic arithmetic all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
everyone is freaking out over the wool
flew South by Southwest has been
canceled this is the biggest one of the
biggest pop culture events of the year
in the United States it's wreaking havoc
on all sorts of conferences speeches
public events Italy now is quarantined
sixteen million people and what's even
tougher for Italy is their quarantine
people in their most economically
productive region so they're their
quarantine people in Lombardy which is
where Milan is so the quarantine Venice
or at some of the most famous cities in
Italy a Rome has stopped all public
masses imagine that you have the heart
of the Catholic Church in the most
Catholic country in the world no masses
during Lent nobody can go to a public
Mass that's just what's going on around
Italy what what else is going around it
is wreaking havoc on flights everybody's
freaking out people are going out and
buying all sorts of Purell which is
selling for like $100 a bottle there to
buy paper towels and toilet paper is
very difficult so is this real is this
real or is it a panic let's look at some
of the numbers the outbreak in Italy at
this point is nearly the size of the
outbreak in South Korea okay in South
Korea had a really pretty broad spread
and epidemic even so 60 million people
quarantined half of Italy is shut down
there have only been 73 hundred cases
there have been 366 deaths so even with
the country grinding to a halt we're
talking about a relatively small number
of cases the outbreak in South Korea
right now is tapering off so it was
exploding now it's slowing down same
thing is happening in China it was
exploding obviously that's where it
began and now it's slowing down
China quarantined 60 million people
all right that's a lot of people so
around the world you've got a hundred
and ten thousand 110,000 infections so
far you've got 3,800
deaths so far most of those have been in
China three-quarters of the cases have
been in China right so even when we're
thinking about this I think the way the
media is portraying it it seems like you
know every third person on earth is
dropping like flies because of this
pandemic really we're talking about very
very few cases I mean if you think of
just just a hundred and ten thousand
people that's that's a small town that's
the size of South Bend Indiana where
mayor Pete Budaj
runs the show right so 3,800 deaths
what is the death rate well we're
getting different numbers some people
are saying it's higher than this some
people think it's lower than this but
one number that keeps Cup popping up is
1.6 percent death rate but that doesn't
tell you the whole story right now if
you look at it by age you get a much
better picture for people under 40
reports show that this is no worse than
the flu you get the flu the flu comes
around every year no big deal for people
40 to 49 it's a little bit worse than
the flu for people 50 to 59 it's a
little bit worse than that for people 60
plus now you're getting into a little
more of a danger zone it's considerably
worse than the flu still though not you
know going to wipe out a whole
generation when you get to 70 plus
that's when you get to a 1 in 10 chance
of death so that is pretty serious right
now the fact that when you get to 70
plus is when it really starts to take
off is why the overall death rate has
been skewed up to one point six percent
some people are saying it's higher but
what do we know now that's just the
threat to personal health the other part
of this problem if we're trying to
figure out if the Dems and the media are
just making everybody panic for nothing
or if this is real is the effective of
the wuhan virus on health systems so if
everybody gets chopped fluey all at once
then that's going to overwhelm the
health systems it's gonna overwhelm
hospitals and more people will die than
otherwise would so that's going to cause
the death rate to tick up not because
the virus got any worse but because
of beds in the hospital because there
aren't enough doctors to go around
because everybody's getting sick all at
the same time so what should we do
step one remain calm
whenever the media are trying to get you
excited and agitated you know the first
thing you have to do remain calm
you are very unlikely to face serious
harm from the sweet and sour sicken okay
it's very unlikely the government
however should overreact
so you know we've been hearing
conveniently you always would hear this
from the left that that the Trump
administration is botching this they're
failing they're putting everybody at
risk right they would have said that
regardless of what the Trump
administration had done the Trump
administration appointed the number two
person in America the vice president to
lead the task force and that's still not
good enough for the left wingers so the
government is is overreacting right now
that's a good thing the government needs
to overreact to quell fears public fears
and economic fears there is a far
greater risk of problems if everybody
freaks out and starts hoarding and
overwhelming the health care system and
tanking the economy then you could get
into a troublesome situation so I think
it's good that the Trump administration
is overreacting also is this a Dem panic
yes the Democrats are obviously
exploiting this for political purposes
the media are obviously exploiting this
for their own political advantage how do
we know that we'll get to that in a
second first I got to thank our friends
over at fairway meat market fairway is a
family owned grocery chain that's been
in business since 1938 fairways premium
beef and all-natural pork is raised by
family farmers and hand cut by a highly
experienced team of fairway butchers
from ribs to rib eyes pork chops beef
tenderloin this stuff is really really
good they're certified de rock heritage
pork is crafted in small batches by
Midwest family farms making it the most
succulent pork you have ever tasted I
had some I had the pork just about a
week ago and it was fabulous it was
excellent excellent pork and then I made
myself a New York strip steak from
fairway but two nights ago and it was
sweet as well it was really really
really good fairway meat market calm
also gives you free access to recipes
this week my listeners get the heartland
package
valued at $230 for just $99.99 plus free
shipping when entering knowles at
checkout the Heartland package includes
eight 8-ounce all-natural Duroc boneless
pork chops 6-8 ounce USD choice ribeye
steaks one mouth-watering side dish
loaded bit potato baked gourmet cheesy
corn or brisket baked beans that's more
than 50% off the best meat in America
Plus free shipping fairway meat market
compro McConnell's look for the
heartland package that's fairway meat
market calm promo code Knowles look for
the heartland package yeah they're
obviously the media are exploiting this
for political purposes we'll see why in
just one second but even before we see
all their reasons for it just remember
you can't trust the media okay they've
lied to us repeatedly they will do
anything they can to reduce Trump's
chances at reelection look at how they
have handled news coverage for just the
last three and a half years forget even
before that they've made things up out
of whole cloth the Russia collusion hoax
they do you remember ABC News when when
Trump was rearranging some forces in the
Middle East and he was pulling some
troops out of Syria they they ran
footage showing the Turks bombing our
greatest ally ever or the Kurds and this
was devastating and was meant to make
Trump look terrible the video was from a
gun show in Kentucky two years ago well
it wasn't even from this year and it
wasn't certainly was it from Syria
that's what we get from the mainstream
media so please forgive me if I'm a
little skeptical of of their coverage so
what should you do you should use common
sense which is something that the
mainstream media certainly will not tell
you but it is the best advice in times
like these the way I know that this is
I'm not saying the wuhan virus is
nothing I'm saying you should take a lot
of precautions but the way I know that
this is at least in part a dem panic is
that the Dems are panicking about so
many other things too mostly the fact
that their chances of winning the
presidency in 2020 are dropping every
single day the establishment of the less
has coalesced right now around Joe Biden
right so they're all coming together
Cory Booker just when I woke up this
morning he sent out a tweet about how
important it is we got to endorse Joe
Biden right Cory pizza I forgot Cory
Booker was even running in the race at
one point every single day however Joe
Biden seems less and less lucid and on
the left or there spinning up as many
narratives about this as they can but
it's pretty clear joe is losing his
marbles we saw this the other night Joe
was at a campaign event he forgot
Barack Obama's name we have a conversion
of the road to Damascus because now you
say by the way are you gonna stick with
the President on the following president
no the last guy on this issue and just
start naming them whatever it is
President ooh
the last guy president Alaska only
that's what his name was so that was one
event now people are gonna write this
off they'll say Oh Joe he just changed
his train of thought look he was just
going and makes it easier to relate to
people start with the last guy it's no
big deal you're looking too far into it
no he forgot his name how do I know that
Joe Biden forgot Barack Obama's name
because he did it again
is his well you're gonna tell me that
that he just changed his mind he was
just actually changing the way he spoke
no he forgot the guy's name it was
president my boss president my boss look
this would be bad if anybody in the
country forgot the last presidents name
it's especially embarrassing for Joe
Biden who worked for the guy for eight
years as his vice president so he's
clearly forgetting names as happens to
people as they get a little bit older
usually they're on train for president
at the time but then he didn't just
forget his former employers name former
president
he's also forgetting his own name
[Applause]
Democrat a proud Democrat and I'll Biden
bomber Democrat join us if you want to
nominate an O Biden bomber Democrat I
think Joe Biden just made Barack Obama
much more Irish than he was
Oh Biden better not quit say no Biden
hello how are you all doing hey not good
and not a good look if it were just once
you could forgive it if it were just
even twice you could this is in keeping
with a pattern all right and Joe Biden
is showing signs of decline and now
we're gonna notice all of those signs
have declined much more it's amazing the
way that the Left treats the legacy of
Ronald Reagan Ronald Reagan throughout
his presidency he had maybe the quickest
wit of any president we've had possibly
other than Donald Trump that guy's
pretty quick on his feet too he turned
the economy around gave us 25 years of
prosperity he won the Cold War
right in the latter days of his
presidency held intense one-on-one
negotiations with Mikhail Gorbachev and
they say he was demented he was senile
he had Alzheimer's at the end of his
presidency they insist on that any
left-wing documentary biography of
Ronald Reagan will talk about how he was
showing signs of decline at the end of
his present
see Joe Biden is showing way clearer
signs of decline at before his
presidency before he even gets to a
general election to try to win the
presidency obviously total hypocrisy
here a complete double standard it's not
even just on the names it's on basic
facts it's on basic policy we'll get to
that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over it keeps speaking of
what happens when we get older do you
know that two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 they
will listen I'm not exactly a hulking
Adonis of a man one thing that's always
kept me in good stead with the ladies I
said a hair with today's advancements in
science keeps offers proven treatments
that can combat the symptoms of hair
loss and help you keep the hair you have
at half the cost of your local pharmacy
but the key here is prevention
okay keeps is up to 90 percent effective
at reducing and stopping further hair
loss so the sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you'll say you got to act
fast if you are ready to take action
right now and prevent hair loss and it's
up to you you can do it you've just got
to take that first step you go to keeps
calm / Michael mi CH AE L you will get
your first month of treatment free
consider that my gift to you that is K
EEP s.com
slash Michael keeps go over check it out
now so he's forgetting names
it's forgetting who we used to work for
he's also getting really basic facts
completely wrong you remember in one of
the recent debates that Joe Biden was
arguing with Bernie Sanders about gun
control and he made the claim that since
2007 guns have killed 150 million
Americans that is half the country and
50 million people have been killed since
2007 when Bernie voted to exempt the gun
manufacturers from liability more than
all the wars including Vietnam from that
point on you think that the media are
trying to scare people with the wuhan
virus Joe Biden saying guns are gonna
kill half of the country of course
not true didn't happen completely
ridiculous we would we wouldn't have a
country anymore if half the people drop
dead over the course of a decade and a
half
some leftists are trying to blame this
on Joe Biden's childhood stutter I kid
you not because they realize the only
thing they have the only arrow in their
quiver is identity victimhood politics
and Joe Biden is many things but he's
not a victim right even according to
their own identity politics pyramid of
victimhood
he's like the least victimized person on
earth he's a straight white man who's
old who's had political power for 50
years right there's no way to paint this
guy as a victim so what they're doing
now is saying that if you make fun of
Joe Biden if you tell any jokes about
him if you suggest you let's say you're
not even making fun of him you're just
saying gosh maybe this guy shouldn't be
on the campaign trail since he can't
remember his own name if you say that
what you're really doing is making fun
of him for his childhood stutter so
they're saying it's all because of this
childhood stutter it's not that he's
he's cognitively declining it's just a
speech thing where was this childhood
stutter for the past forty years if this
is a childhood stutter that just
conveniently and suddenly reappeared why
is it reappearing it doesn't like it
they're speaking as though we don't know
who Joe Biden is you know speaking as
though we've never seen him before Joe
Biden has been in the public eye for a
very long time and he wasn't talking
like this five years ago or ten years
ago or 15 years ago he's talking about
this now because he's obviously
declining by the way how does a child
with a childhood stutter cause you to
get basic math wrong how does a
childhood stutter cause you to forget
your boss's name how does a childhood
stutter cause you to forget your own
name doesn't not at all by the way I
want to remind you we are gonna be
taking listener questions during the
show so that's only for daily wire
subscribers if you're on the website or
the app write your questions and we'll
take them we have one right now from LL
do we all need to pray to the thing for
Biden's health
it's a very indicative question that's a
very illustrative question of course we
should we should always pray to the
thing hopefully we we can remember the
things named but yes and you actually
reminded me I would have completely
forgotten a Joe Biden dropped the words
of the Declaration of Independence most
famous words in all of American history
we hold these truths to be self-evident
because we all these truths to be
self-evident that all men and when women
and you you know the thing is that it's
that's a stutter he was able to say the
thing you just wasn't able to say the
words so my favorite one of these I
think is a Joe Biden apparently calling
for the re-election of Donald Trump I
don't know if you saw this over the
weekend President Trump himself tweeted
out here's Joe from a campaign that's
about negative attacks in the one about
what were for because we cannot get
reelected we cannot win this reelection
excuse me we can only reelect damn it
I agree you're right we can't only
reelect Donald Trump it's the only thing
to do and right now all things being
equal it's the only thing we will do was
that a childhood stutter when you
endorse your opponent is that that's
because of a childhood stutter I don't
think so I think it's because you're
forgetting where you are you know Joe is
not going to be able to do this on his
own this actually ties in to the
question of is the wuhan virus a
pandemic or a Dem panic the whole media
apparatus is going to come and circle
around Joe Biden when that video came
out of Joe Biden saying look the only
thing we can do is reelect Donald Trump
a few conservatives tweeted this around
the president tweeted this around
Twitter flagged it as manipulated media
Twitter put this new policy into effect
last Thursday defines manipulated posts
as any photo video or audio that has
been significantly altered or fabricate
a fabricated and it said it could remove
some of the video that caused a serious
harm it hasn't removed that yet how is
that manipulated how is that
manipulated there's no you know
fabricating what he said there's no
fabricating how he looked or where he
was
it's a clip of a video so on the one
hand nobody thinks Joe Biden is really
endorsing Donald Trump right we're all
just having a little bit of fun because
Joe Biden doesn't know how to say his
own name anymore but to the video itself
is not manipulated right where's the
manipulation
I guess the manipulation would be that
they cut it off because if you play the
video for another five minutes he says
we're gonna like Donald Trump if we
don't you know we if we need to come
together we need to come together and
then we won't elect Donald Trump
something like that
so now Twitter is saying that any video
that has an endpoint that they don't
like is manipulated video literally
every video that has ever been made is
manipulated in this way because videos
don't go on forever they're not infinite
if any video has a beginning and an end
point it is by this definition
manipulated so is Twitter gonna start
taking down all the left wing videos I
guess would be every video right because
every video begins and ends somewhere
mmm something tells me they want
something tells me they're going to use
this completely vague new policy only to
attack conservatives this is maybe the
most egregious expansion of their
censorship policy I've seen yet to say
that if the left does this all the time
whenever we catch them on video tape
being complete degenerate s-- they you
know whenever we catch Planned
Parenthood saying that they buy and sell
body parts and then want to buy
Lamborghinis you know what they say they
say it's a selectively edited video and
then the right comes and says no wait we
mean it's selectively edit here's the
whole video we just click record and
then it goes on to the end I said no
it's selectively edited you didn't get
before or after yeah I couldn't film
forever I you know I can't well no time
but here it is on video they say
selectively edited now Twitter is taking
that up as well this is what I mean this
is why we can't
no weather big issues raised in the
media whether it's one virus or some
political question whether it's real or
not because none of these people are
honest brokers of information they all
have an interest in and an ability to
warp the news to push their own
propaganda they are desperate nowhere is
this clearer than in the endorsements
and lack of endorsements that are coming
in for Joe Biden from the demo
stablishment it there's really really
pathetic we'll get to that in a second
first I got a thing our friends over at
ray con oh man first of all if you are
still using earbuds headphones that have
wires you are living in another
civilization we have there is very
little we have in common I don't even
know how to relate to your life
experience it is 20/20 you need to get a
pair of wireless earbuds and unlike some
of your other wireless options ray con
earbuds are both stylish and discreet no
dangling wires or stems as drew says
that'll make you look like a bug
ray con just released their best model
yet the e25 s they're really cool six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and a more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating v no wireless earbuds look
better than ray cons the sound quality
is superb and best of all they don't
gouge you on the price they're a very
fair price get 15% off your order up by
raking comm slash Knowles Cana wles
that's by rake on.com slash Knowles
canna wles for 15% off rake on wireless
earbuds buy rake on comm slash knowles
so the way that you know that the
democrat establishment is settling for
joe biden the way you know that they
don't feel that good about it is the
lack of energy in their endorsements so
they tried to avoid it right they tried
to avoid endorsing joe biden they tried
to pick anybody else is it going to be
Pete is it going to be Elizabeth Warren
is it gonna be no they all flopped now
it seems inevitable and they're still
dragging their feet finally yesterday
calm
Harris who we also forgot ran for
president at one point she endorsed Joe
Biden in the lamest most reluctant way I
think I've ever heard supporting me for
so long and I just wanted you guys smell
I have decided that I am with great
enthusiasm I'm going to endorse Joe
Biden for President of the United States
I believe in gentlemen I really believe
in him and I have known him for a long
time one of the things that we need
right now is we need a leader who really
does care about the people and who can
therefore unify the people and I believe
Joe can do that I am supporting Joe
because I believe that he is a man who
has lived his life with great dignity he
is a public servant who has always
worked for the best of who we are as a
nation and we need that right now there
is so much at stake in this election
guys so join me in supporting Joe and
let's get this done ah
let's support Joe let's just join me
we're gonna support Joe she looks like
she's in a hostage video she's up
against this white brick wall very stark
lighting cameras making weird sounds the
lighting is awful I mean the shadows are
really bad and she's there like who's
she trying to convince yeah I really
like Joe no I think he's really great
he's good and he'll be good and so let's
endorse him
Pamela Harris if you will recall all the
way back to those early democratic 2020
debates started her campaign by saying
that she wasn't accusing Joe Biden of
racism and then immediately accusing Joe
Biden of racism in this campaign we've
also heard and I'm gonna now direct this
at Vice President Biden I do not believe
you are a racist and I agree with you
when you commit yourself to the
importance of finding common ground but
I also believe and it is personal and I
was actually very it was hurtful to hear
you talk about the reputations of two
United States senators who built their
reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country and
it was not only that but you also worked
with them to oppose busing and you know
there was a little girl in California
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bused to school every day and that
little girl was me Oh
Kamala what a tangled web we weave when
we hurl accusations of bigotry to
deceive so what she's talking about
there is that Joe Biden had had bragged
about his ability to work with people he
disagreed with specifically he was
talking about two southern
segregationist Democrats Mississippi
Senator James Eastland and Georgia
senator Herman Talmadge and he said look
we disagreed but I was able to work with
them on specific legislation and get
things done and then Camilla twisted
this and said Joe works with
segregationists Joe is a racist Joe's a
terrible guy she twisted it what he was
saying which was actually the opposite
for a cheap political point there is a
political lesson in here which is don't
call people bigots unless you mean it
one because it's wrong it's really wrong
to do that I mean in America today just
in the pop culture the worst thing you
can possibly be called is a racist and
she just does it willy-nilly I'm not
calling you a racist Joe but you're
definitely a big racist I mean the left
this all the time it's not just common
low Harris's problem so that's the one
reason the moral reason not to do it is
it's wrong the personal reason not to do
it is you look very foolish if you use
the cheapest political trick you've got
call the other guy racist and then the
race doesn't turn out your way and you
end up having to endorse the racist
because that's what as if she did it's I
think part of the reason why she looked
so reluctant in that endorsement video
she says uh gosh well I know I look like
a fool
what was I thinking now Pamela Harris at
least dragged herself and was able to go
and endorse him there's one very
prominent member of the Democratic Party
who just hasn't been able to do it yet
and this probably is the biggest threat
we've seen so far to Joe Biden getting
that Democratic nomination we will get
to that in a second we will get to
Bernie's big problem and we will get to
Brian Williams of MSNBC and Maura gay of
the New York Times failing at basic
arithmetic but first I've got a second
bite of Facebook in YouTube and right
now we're offering 25 percent off all
daily wire membership plans when you use
coupon code never socialist it's
important you remember that code just
like it's important that you'll Biden
remembers the Declaration of
Independence or his bosses name or his
own name
because we are approaching the end of
this offer and you will want to act fast
you get everything you get inside op-eds
from ben shapiro you get exclusive
access to ask questions you get the
leftist ears tumblr you get everything
25% off daily wire memberships for all
plans using coupon code never socialist
head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe remember this the last week
this deal will be available so act now
before it's too late
daily wire.com slash subscribe we'll be
right back with a lot more
all right a listener question from JH
hey Michael how can the left even stand
on its stance of abortion and at the
same time screamed that we can't have
milk products the reason that the left
is advocating for the environment or
animal rights or the milk thing that's
the new leftist
political cause du jour is that we can't
drink milk anymore is not because it
will help anybody
it won't help the earth it won't help
the cows it won't help anybody it's so
that it will hurt you that's what you
have to understand people are always
confused how can a vegan be in favor of
abortion right it doesn't make sense if
you think of this as a way to save a
human baby or less important save a
little cow or save a little pig or
something
that doesn't make any sense if you look
at it from the perspective of preserving
life but if you look at it from the
perspective of hurting yourself doing
penance atoning for your sins then it
makes a whole lot of sense normal people
have religion we have regular religion
we're aware that we are broken that we
have a fallen nature that we sin often
and we have fallen short of the glory of
God and we need to make some sort of
atonement for that we need to have a
little bit of penance we need to confess
our sins we have to acknowledge them you
know when you go to Mass when you go to
not just Catholic but other other
services too
you say I've sinned through my fault
through my fault through my most
grievous fault and you strike your
breast right you're just a little
reminder that you've you've done
something wrong and you're taking some
penance for that the left doesn't have
regular religion but they still have all
the religious longings of people they
still know that they've fallen short of
the glory of God they still know that
they're imperfect so they have to do
penance so for them in this case it
would be animal rights you could call it
global warming whatever they Institute
policies that won't help anything but it
will hurt them so the milk problem right
if they just abstained from eating me
if they just did that alone that would
obviously do a lot more to help the
animals than them not drinking milk
actually cows hurt when you don't milk
them but not drinking milk not eating
cheese not having yogurt not eating ice
cream right that's a that's a deeper
punishment than just abstaining from
from certain meat products it's the same
thing with the plastic straws the
plastic straw does not do anything right
it is is a fraction of a fraction of a
fraction of a scintilla of an iota of a
fraction of plastic pollution it doesn't
matter at all but we feel it when we go
to the coffee shop and they won't give
us our straw and they give us that
stupid paper thing that dissolves and
then we start chewing on paper we feel
that and we feel sorrow for our own sin
of pollution that's what it's all about
it's just about hurting them if they got
regular religion they wouldn't have to
do all this weird stuff getting back to
20/20 so Kamala Harris endorses Joe
Biden reluctantly Cory Booker endorses
Joe Biden on Twitter one Democrat
doesn't want to endorse Joe Biden that
would be our future or former future
president Hillary Rodham Clinton who was
on Fareed Zakaria's show she was asked
about Bernie Sanders she attacked Bernie
Sanders she said Bernie wouldn't be the
right choice for the party logical next
question does that mean you're endorsing
Bernie does that mean you're endorsing
Biden rather she will not agree to it is
the Democratic nominee will you campaign
for him I will support the nominee of
the Democratic Party will you campaign
for him I don't know if he would ask me
to campaign for him for Reid because I
have no idea what he is thinking about
for a general election campaign as I've
said many times I do not think he's our
strongest nominee against Donald Trump
is that an endorsement of Joe Biden I'm
not endorsing there's nobody left well I
guess that's true there is anybody left
that's right I'm not endorsing uh-uh
what this screams to me is that
Democrats most of all Hillary are still
holding out hope that there will be a
different nominee and
probably in Hillary's mind that nominee
would most likely be Hillary I'm not
saying that that's gonna happen I'm not
saying that they think that's gonna
happen I'm saying they're holding out
hope if Hillary Clinton did not think
somewhere in the way way back of her
absolutely sociopathic limitless
ambition mind she didn't think there was
some chance that she could get this
nomination through some crazy series of
events she would just endorse Joe Biden
there were two candidates left it's Joe
Biden it's Bernie Sanders
she said Bernie Sanders would be the
wrong choice so she should endorse Joe
Biden right this is different than Obama
not endorsing Biden for Obama he doesn't
want to irritate the Bernie Bros he
doesn't want to be on the losing side he
doesn't want to be on the wrong side of
history
he's totally concerned about his own
legacy and who will be the heir to his
legacy that's why he's refraining from
commenting at all about this election
Hillary's already out there Hillary has
already said Bernie would not be the
best choice Bernie would be weak nobody
likes Bernie that's what she said the
other day she ran a campaign against
Bernie all right her antipathy to Bernie
and the Bernie bros is clear as day so
there's no reason not to endorse Joe
Biden except that maybe she's hoping
someone else will walk into that
contested convention and walk out with
the nomination and oh gosh wouldn't that
be just wonderful because there's
increasing evidence by the way that
Bernie Sanders is not even going to put
up the sort of fight that we expected
him to two weeks ago we thought Bernie
Sanders is gonna run away with this
nomination remember he was in the lead
in the delegate lead he was winning all
the early states and then he hit that
Joe Biden firewall in South Carolina and
then he had Super Tuesday and he started
to drop why did he drop the main story
we've been told us because he can't get
minority voters that's true the other
problem is that his base doesn't show up
to the polls his base turns out bunch of
like unemployed college kids who smoke
pot all day turns out not the most
reliable voters I know shocking
that's so Bernie Sanders has been
relying on the youth vote coming out and
supporting him in droves
trouble is they're staying home so in
California right California Bernie
Sanders winzip young voters helped him
but voters under the age of 30 made up
just 11% of the electorate according to
exit polls then another 35 percent were
between 45 and 64 and 30% were 65 and
older so Bernie even had to acknowledge
that his young voter strategy is failing
he said quote have we been as successful
as I would hope in bringing young people
in the answer is no North Carolina
another state that Sanders could have
won Joe Biden ended up winning it on
Super Tuesday but Bernie was pretty
competitive there he did not get the
young voters to turnout young voter
turnout was 9% very very weak so if
Bernie's gonna turn this campaign around
he's got to expand his base he's
probably not going to be able to do that
which means that Joe Biden who is now
proven the electability argument is
still sound is going to expand his base
he's probably going to do a very good
job the question then becomes can Joe
Biden get across the finish line win
this thing outright or is there gonna be
wheeling and dealing at the convention
if there is wheeling and dealing that's
a whole new ballgame because well Joe
Biden might be winning the votes in this
very weak primary field and this was a
very weak primary field a lot of
Democratic Party elites don't believe
that he's the guy to go up against
Donald Trump in 2020 he can't remember
his own name they're not gonna tell you
that they're not gonna tell you that on
the news they're gonna lie to you on the
news but in a their private studies
that's what they're thinking and so
there is a chance however small then
another candidate emerges and boy would
that be hilarious now I've been a little
harsh on the mainstream media today I'm
a little harsh on the mainstream media
every single day I've said the reason
that you can't really believe them is
because they're so hyper partisan
because there's such a liar's because
they carry water for democratic
candidates that's true that's part of
the reason why you can't believe them
when it comes to something even like
maybe their hysteria over the corona
virus
the other reason you can't believe them
is because they're not very smart I know
we think that if you go into the media
you probably went to a fancy school
you've probably read a lot of books you
have us a fancy suit with a nice necktie
on so therefore you must be very
intelligent no no you don't have to be
Brian Williams of MSNBC and a New York
Times editorial board member Mara gay
put this myth this canard of media
intelligence to rest the other day when
they described how Mike Bloomberg who
spent five hundred million dollars at
least on his primary campaign could have
given at least one million dollars to
every one of the 300 million Americans
with that money here they are trying to
work it out in their minds you see it as
a possibility if he wants to spend a
billion bucks beating this guy he could
do it absolutely
somebody tweeted recently that actually
with the money he spent he could have
given every American a million dollars
got it let's put it up a screen it when
I read it tonight on social media it
kind of all became clear
Bloomberg spent 500 million on ads u.s.
population 327 million don't tell us if
you're ahead of us on the math he could
have given each American 1 million
dollars and I've had lunch money left
over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's true it's disturbing it does it
does suggest you know what we're talking
about here which is there's too much
money in politics I don't know if a
producer or somebody wrote the segment
and then Brian Williams and Maura Gaye
just derailed it because they couldn't
understand it but the the pitch is so
easy right which is here's this tweet
kind of a funny tweet says that Mike
Bloomberg spent five hundred million
dollars on his campaign and so they're
three over 300 million Americans so he
could have given each American correct
answer is like a little over a dollar
right dollar fifty it's something like
that because it could have given each
and every American a million dollars
and so so Brian Williams says now hold
on a second if you're ahead of us on the
math here first of all we're all ahead
of you on the math now Brian Williams we
now know that but it seemed as though
he's gonna say you're ahead of us on the
math
obviously this tweet doesn't make any
sense these guys got there their orders
of magnitude a little bit off and anyway
what a silly tweet instead Brian
Williams total straight basic owes what
an amazing number and now at this point
you would hope that Ron burgandy over
here would be corrected by his far more
intelligent on-air colleague this woman
from the New York Times right except no
because she can't do the math either so
she goes yes it isn't me it's amazing
because it's true no it's a MIT what is
amazing is that you people can't do
basic math you are at elite media
institutions MSNBC Brian Williams is the
former anchor of NBC News Morag a New
York Times editorial board the grey lady
all the news that's fit to print and
then I love it the it just hits you with
that second punch line at the end she
says and it just goes to show you that
there's too much money in politics no it
shows that there's too much authority
placed in the mainstream media it shows
you that we give these guys way too much
credibility it doesn't show you that
there's too much money in politics
please for the last time New York Times
I know you're watching this the Mike
Bloomberg campaign shows you
definitively that there is not too much
money in politics if money in politics
were a really really big problem then
Mike Bloomberg would have been able to
buy the presidency but he didn't was not
able to do that completely wrong
conclusion from completely wrong math
from very subpar journalists they don't
know how to do basic math I think
there's a problem on the left
generally the left doesn't know the
difference between a million and a
billion in two trillion they don't know
they don't understand what the zeros do
to numbers I'm not even really being
facetious here I'm not
rating too much when Bernie Sanders
comes out with a plan for health care or
for education or whatever plans 100
trillion dollars AOC right AOC comes up
with a plan that was almost 100 trillion
dollars called the green New Deal
93 trillion dollar plan at no point does
she ask herself where am I gonna get
that money because in her mind
93 trillion 93 billion 93 million 93
bucks yeah look it's all the same he's
got 93 in it it's all the same her plan
for how to pay for it would be exactly
the same if it were a trillion or if it
were a million even though those numbers
are vastly vastly different it's the
same here Mike bloom what they were
seeing is Mike Bloomberg spent a lot of
money and there are a lot of people so
Mike Bloomberg could give a lot of money
to a lot of people we started off the
show asking is this a pandemic or a Dem
panic should we believe the media hype
here I think most of the media hype is
malicious I think most of the media hype
not just on the coronavirus but on
everything in our politics is from a
place of deep bias and a desire to screw
this up for Donald Trump
however we should never ascribe to
malice that which can be equally
explained by stupidity and the
mainstream media are showing that every
single day either way the conclusion
remains the same keep calm
listen to honest brokers read people who
you think have a good grasp on things
and and this is the part the media
definitely don't want you to do think
for yourself that's our show I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stevens assistant director Havel
without ski editor and associate
producer Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the michael knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you